well why not ditch the traditional sugar
lace candy basket for easter this year
and opt for something healthier and fun
yes our mommy vlogging expert has some
great ideas for all ages plus a way to
give to ukrainian relief
[Music]
the hottest new games toys and
activities perfect for this year's
easter amanda mushroo is a nationally
recognized parenting expert and mom they
can make whatever they want with these
magnets the styko fishing 26 piece set
for magformer is perfect for toddlers
brain development and critical thinking
and you can keep kids busy with it
wherever you go if you go out to easter
brunch but i also like this for travel
since they're magnetic you can take them
in the car and then quickly kind of
scoop everything up school bus wagon
from green toys can help parents out in
two ways i think this would be so cute
as an easter basket itself you could
just fill up all of their goodies inside
and it's the perfect size for little
ones to haul around their most prized
possessions plus it's dishwasher safe my
kids always take their green toys into
the bathtub and then it makes it out
into the sandbox so it is designed for
that check out these reeboks rebooted
robots from tames and cosmos start with
one or collect all four kits mix up the
interchangeable parts i like the idea
that they get something in their easter
basket and they can put those stem
skills their building engineering for
the tweens and teens who can be a bit
difficult to shop for some beautiful
jewelry the easter collection by luca
and danny some have rabbits or you can
personalize with names they also offer
this sunflower 50 percent of the
sunflower bengal sales will be donated
to sunflower of peace to support the
people of ukraine
now for the kids into squishies and
poppets the board game go pop presto is
a good one we've got the links also for
the ukrainian relief efforts on our
website at 8newsnow.com